But seriously, we all say we hate this crap.
The question is whether you're willing to make
a personal sacrifice to change it.
I don't mean giving up the Internet.
I mean changing the way you click,
because clicking is a public act.
It's no longer the case
that a few powerful elites control all the media
and the rest of us are just passive receivers.
Increasingly, we're all the media.
I used to think, oh, okay, I get dressed up,
I put on a lot of makeup,
I go on television, I talk about the news.
That is a public act of making media.
And then I go home and I browse the web
and I'm reading Twitter,
and that's a private act of consuming media.
I mean, of course it is. I'm in my pajamas.
Wrong.
Everything we blog, everything we Tweet,
and everything we click
is a public act of making media.
We are the new editors.
We decide what gets attention
based on what we give our attention to.
That's how the media works now.
There's all these hidden algorithms that decide
what you see more of and what we all see more of
based on what you click on,
and that in turn shapes our whole culture.
Over three out of five Americans think we have
a major incivility problem in our country right now,
but I'm going to guess that at least three out of five
Americans are clicking on the same insult-oriented,
rumor-mongering trash that feeds
the nastiest impulses in our society.
In an increasingly noisy media landscape,
the incentive is to make more noise to be heard,
and that tyranny of the loud
encourages the tyranny of the nasty.
It does not have to be that way.
It does not.
We can change the incentive.
For starters, there are two things we can all do.
First, don't just stand by the sidelines when you see someone getting hurt.
If someone is being abused online, do something.
Be a hero. This is your chance.
Speak up. Speak out. Be a good person.
Drown out the negative with the positive.
And second, we've got to stop clicking
on the lowest-common-denominator, bottom-feeding
linkbait.
If you don't like the 24/7 all Kardashian
all the time programming,
you've got to stop clicking on the stories
about Kim Kardashian's sideboob.
I know you do it. (Applause)
You too, apparently.
I mean, really, same example:
if you don't like politicians calling each other names,
stop clicking on the stories
about what one guy in one party called the other guy in the other party.
Clicking on a train wreck just pours gasoline on it.
It makes it worse, the fire spreads.
Our whole culture gets burned.
If what gets the most clicks wins,
then we have to start shaping the world we want
with our clicks,
because clicking is a public act.
So click responsibly. Thank you.
(Applause)